so right-wing media has been just
falling all over itself to preemptively
excuse the alleged massive tax fraud
committed by Donald Trump and his family
as has been outlined in this very
extensively sourced New York Times
investigation that came out this week
which we talked about on yesterday's
show we know that in the eyes of his
supporters Trump can do absolutely no
wrong but there's actually extra support
on tax dodging from the right because
many of the people that are on the
American right-wing fundamentally see
taxes as unfair and immoral so in their
eyes it's okay to break the law if it's
to avoid paying taxes because the taxes
are unfair to begin with and one such
person appears to be Fox News host Neil
Cavuto who's basically the caricature of
mr. moneybags from the Monopoly game in
real life so as a reminder we are
talking here not about minor tax fraud
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of dollars in alleged tax fraud by
Donald Trump's family including bogus
real estate valuations to avoid taxes
and all sorts of other mechanisms that
the New York Times outlined in their
investigation as a reminder actor Wesley
Snipes a lot of people emailed me
yesterday saying David that's actually
an interesting comparison actor Wesley
Snipes went to prison for three years
for much less than what Donald Trump and
his family are accused of here but Neil
Cavuto from Fox News thinks that the
entire thing is clever
this was clever take a look at this
video clip from Fox News and Neil Cavuto
all right governor Kentucky here we're
learning a little bit more about some of
the revelations made in this New York
Times report that takes a look at the
wealth of kinda cheap Trump dating back
to the Sun and all Trump and his dad of
course who was a real estate magnate
back in the 50s and 60s and his
acquisitions of frequent run-ins with
the IRS for example but none of them
deemed ultimately illegal that they
might have played fast and loose to
acquire the wealth they did and did in
fact have run-ins
the IRS but none that resulted in the
IRS aggressively going after them they
were just pretty clever and out dodge
them this is criminal right if these
allegations are true these are criminal
actions law and order is what they claim
to be in favor of except when they see
it as unfair like paying taxes as
determined by I guess whoever decides
that they don't like taxes to begin with
think about how when the left points out
that all these people that are in prison
because they possess marijuana if that's
not fair that really shouldn't be a
crime what is the right say they will
say you can wish that it wasn't a crime
you can lobby for it to no longer be a
crime but it's a crime and were a
country of laws so those people must be
held accountable but now all of a sudden
the narrative is that Trump and his
family's fraudulent tactics to escape
taxation aren't criminal but they're
clever but the real thieves are those on
welfare who don't deserve $200 a month
in food stamps that they get for example
this is why Trump appeals to many on the
right and the small government crowd
it's not because he's actually for small
government it's because he flouts the
laws of the country with regard to
taxation and business regulation and so
much more in a way that the right and
the anti-government people love and you
know when you call it clever you're
basically saying that you are smart to
not obey the law but then they say
therefore law and order is out dodging
to use Neil Cavuto phrase is out dodging
the police by shooting an officer for
example is that clever I mean it's a
pretty clever way of getting away right
if you shoot the officer he can't come
after you no Republicans aren't going to
say that is burglarizing the homes of
innocent people a clever way of not
having to buy your own stuff I mean
that's pretty slick right no Republicans
aren't going to use the term clever when
it comes to that and there's always this
kind of grand narrative from the right
around Trump
he definitely didn't collude with Russia
but if he did it wasn't illegal and it
was actually smart like why not try to
win an election anyway that you can he
definitely didn't do anything fraudulent
or illegal when it comes to taxes but if
he did it's a pretty clever way of
dodging the IRS right I've been using
this term and it applies here weaponized
cognitive dissonance weaponized
cognitive dissonance that is how Donald
Trump has been able to bamboozle these
supporters into goalposts moving erratic
behavior where you start with he
definitely didn't do it and you move to
if he didn't it was it if he did do it
it wasn't illegal and then you move to
it's smart to do it
Trump did it because he's smart send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show on Twitter at David Pakman show
we've got a good one for you today one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an incredible online learning
community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video we'll get to
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than ten bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up